Hello everyone and welcome back to EUpeople
Today we connect with Roberto Viola
a techie at the head of the digital department of the European Commission
Together we will browse EU digital policies
and see how decisions taken
today will affect your life tomorrow!
We will also navigate his past, pick up some old phones and plug into satellites...
Your Wi-Fi is working? Your phone is fully
charged? Then let's begin!
I am delighted to welcome
Roberto Viola, the digital guru of the European Commission.
Some say he only sleeps four hours and a half a day
Others that he has brain hardwired for technology.
The man who once gave powerful people a headache is full of mysteries...
But one thing is for sure:
Roberto's work will shape the digital world for the next 20 years, at least.
How, you ask? Let’s find out.
Good morning Roberto! Good morning Romain
Would you call yourself a digital guru?
I would say a digital savvy...
I've seen a picture of you building a computer in the 80s... how come?
It was the time of the first computers...
They were the first personal computers coming on the market
and it was common for the digital
gurus at that time to build their own computers
I became rather successful: all
my family and friends were asking for computers
I could have open a
business!
The house was full of pieces of
computers, memories.
I didn't know we could build a computer even!
You could do this. Still you can do it nowadays. It's not that common.
Could you tell us in few simple words: what is the digital single market ?
Oh it's a beautiful thing! In Europe you can move around and you don't feel you're changing country.
You don't pay roaming fees. You have the same rules for privacy. You can shop online.
You can watch your favorite movies, your
favorite sports across borders.
How do you do with evolving technologies:
I guess there's a balance to make between regulation and also letting the technology blossom
So how do you keep this balance?
It's very difficult and you have to keep this balance indeed.
You have to allow people to innovate to
really disrupt all the things and create new ones.
At the same time people also need to
be protected.
There should be transparency for the customers.
The rights of the people have to be respected: privacy, individuality.
I mean, you always have to keep this fine balance.
To make it understandable to
people: could you explain me some key words
in one sentence and what the EU is doing in these fields.
So let's start with "Internet of Things"?
Well it's everything connected to the Internet: your fridge that tells you to buy milk when it is finished
Do you have a smart fridge?
Not yet, not yet...I'll build one!
And what the EU is doing?
The EU is fostering this technology, its
standardization, its safety
to make sure for instance that your
own camera is not spying you
and at the same time is useful to protect your home.
Artificial intelligence?
Well, it's a computer that can understand things from many different data and things that are
happening around and gives you a
prediction of what is going to happen.
And the EU in this field?
The EU is doing many things. It is basically introducing artificial intelligence everywhere
for the benefit of the citizens
financing research and also working
on ethics.
Big data?
It's a big 0 and big 1- I'm joking of course.
Big data is zillions of data that we generate with our smart watch, smartphone,
This sea of data can be searched by artificial intelligent machines
and allow you to understand much better how things work.
Geo blocking?
You felt it I'm sure.
Have you tried to shop online and at the
end the website says "sorry I don't ship in your country"
Like for Christmas...
It's when you tried to rent a car and you were redirected to a website you didn't want to go...
These are forms of geo blocking.
And the EU is trying to prevent it?
It has abolished it. There is an EU regulation abolishing geoblocking.
I mean from Christmas onwards, people will be free to shop online wherever they like.
And what happens... if not?
If you're still geo blocked?
If you're still geoblocked, call me!
Ok, so we're going to put the phone number of Roberto Viola on screen...
Cybersecurity?
It's protecting online everything which has to do with the movement of data
and making sure that people don't spy on your computer or your smartphone
don't attack banks or hospitals.
It's a very serious thing.
And fake news?
We call it disinformation.
It's all the attempts to alter equitable ways of representing information
by people that don't have really good intentions.
Can we make the digital world ethical?
Can we apply online the same rules that we have offline?
Absolutely! What applies offline you should apply online.
So how you behave online should be how you behave offline.
People sometimes feel they can
go online and insult others and misbehave
I don't understand why.
You should be as ethical when you are offline and when you use your digital self.
Roberto, you remember your first mobile
phone?
We found it in an old drawer!
You remember how long it took to
type a message and we were limited in characters
So I'd like to start with a
small challenge...
Would you be able to draft the full
regulation on geoblocking on this small phone?
Or alternatively, let's draft "love the digital single market"
ah okay!
I'm gonna do it on mine...
That's unfair!
We'll see! Maybe you'll be quicker...
So shall we? Let's try... Are you
ready?
Start!
I have the autocorrect on...
But that's really unfair!
I'm done!
Done!
Two minutes! I can tell: it's correct!
How was it to play with the phone?
Quite a challenge I must say...
More seriously you were at the head of the European telecom regulators
when mobile phone were booming. How was this experience?
You know when I started as a
regulator, there were no smartphones and no tablets.
To connect to the internet you had to use what they were calling dial-up modem
you had to dial up a number and they were making strange noises when they were connecting
It was quite a different time!
You couldn't connect to the Internet and at the same time use your phone to call...
But what were you regulating at that
time then?
It was the beginning of the most important thing: the introduction of 3G and then 4G
Regulations to allow cheap prices to connect to the internet thanks to EU rules by the way
I have some questions from the online audience about phones
So we got Garrett who is asking: "what does actually roaming mean?"
It's not a difficult one. Roaming it's using your mobile phone when you are outside your home country coverage.
And the EU did a lot to lower prices?
No zero prices! When you are around in Europe you don't pay roaming fees anymore.
Another question from Yaonnis: Europe developed the GSM standards
and today is lagging behind Asia and the U.S. in developing 5G networks
Is it too bureaucratic to adopt new
technologies?
Look: 5G has not yet started so let's give Europe a chance!
We are working hard to help researchers and companies deploy 5G very quickly.
Okay it's not only about regulation it's also about innovation...
It's a lot about innovation as well!
A question from Gerhardt: "why can't Europe create tech giants?"
It's a question that we hear a lot: tech giants like the US or China?
Europe has many industrial giants. It's fair to say it woke up a bit late to the digital revolution
but now we are very serious
so stay tuned I would say!
Where would you think the tech giant's
would be? In which sectors?
I would say digital finance, in robotics, in
healthcare.
I'm sure there will be digital world leaders.
An interesting question: "why are mobile phone bills much higher in the U.S. than in Europe?"
I would say it's a combination of factors.
Mostly in Europe you have more competition.
More competition brings lower
prices?
As always.
Roberto, I'd like to talk about your first
love: space!
You joined the European Space Agency at the age of 25. Did you have the Star Wars syndrome?
Well, probably the Apollo one because
when I saw the moon landing
and I was 11 at that time I said: that's something.
So you studied in that direction and it was really your focus?
I would say my generation had a special love for space
More seriously, I see you brought us a nice miniature of a satellite and it says it's "Galileo"
What is Galileo exactly?
In a word, it's the European GPS. It's a constellation of satellites that allows you to know where you are.
And it's used for technologies as well. Is it used for mobile phones?
It's in mobile phones and it
will be a bit everywhere.
It's a new generation of navigation satellites. It will be even more precise.
Why should Europe have its own
satellites?
First of all Europe needs to have its own satellites because they are used to watch football matches...
What about this! Is it convincing enough?
We have a very good coverage when it comes to satellite television and telecommunication
Now navigation or satellites monitoring the environment
that's super important to understand what is happening whenever there's a natural disaster
to have images to understand and to rescue people
So in many different ways satellites are important.
But there's another important reason why space matters
Space technology is a sort of frontrunner technology.
When you move your phone and the
orientation changes: that's called gyroscope
It was invented for space!
or the touchscreen.
So all the new things you are now using they were already used 20 years ago in space.
That's why I'm a little bit digital savvy now
because I have seen it all some time ago.
What is Europe's future in space? What's the next step: do we go to Mars?
We already went I mean but there are
many things to do many things to do...
The universe is big. Our earth needs
to be understood much better
and we need to continuously evolve
with new technologies
Thank you very much Roberto, thank you for connecting with us
I have the impression we had so many topics to cover that it could be a never-ending discussion
If you want, I have a tent here so we can continue...
Or we could do many episodes if you wish
Thank you everyone for watching
You can comment, share online, you can rewatch the video
There is a last little game we're gonna play with Roberto about European movies
So I suggest you click on this link: it's a bonus video.
Thank you again Roberto!
Thank you very much!